good morning everyone my name is
researcher Miller and the item number
that we're going to be studying today is
scp-2319 ein object class Keter special
containment procedures due to scp-2319
i-ness location and nature physical
means of containment are currently
impossible implanted foundation agents
and major observatories are to contain
footage or images of SCP $23.99 an
ongoing misinformation campaign is in
effect which has thus far been able to
completely suppress any knowledge
pertaining to scp-2319 9 from public
awareness foundation satellites in orbit
around Jupiter are to maintain constant
vigilance of scp-2319 Ines
reconstruction efforts and make all
attempts to hinder that process should
scp-2319 ein reach a minimum of 75
percent completion additionally a
perimeter of long-range electromagnetic
jamming satellites barrier array has
been situated in hyeju pidor 'but any
transmissions intercepted by this array
are to be summarily decoded and logged
in the event of scp-2319 ein surpassing
75 percent completion or an information
breach in the jamming perimeter
necessary foundation personnel will
engage protocol Legionnaire 5c addendum
$23.99 l5 given its completion by that
time
description scp-2319 ein as a massive
complex mechanical structure currently
located in Jupiter's lower atmosphere
since its visual discovery in 1963
scp-2319 ein has been observed to use
highly advanced antimatter based
weaponry to create spatial disruptions
and devastating atmospheric observable
as a large red vortex commonly known as
the Great Red Spot SCP $23.99 appears to
be damaged possibly due to an impact
with the moon Io before coming to rest
in its current position SCP $23.99 has
been observed releasing a multitude of
small octopod repair drones and efforts
to repair the damage it is taken some of
these drones will remain near SCP $23.99
while others will patrol nearby moons or
deeper into the gases of Jupiter itself
in search of parts that scp-2319 ein is
missing computer models estimate that
scp-2319 ein is at 59% completion with a
current rate of point 78 annually this
rate has increased from an estimated
point 12% in 1970 despite its damaged
state scp-2319 ein seems to possess a
limitless power supply advanced
electromagnetic shielding matter
disrupting weaponry the ability to
repair damaged unto itself and precise
tracking and targeting system see
addendum $23.99 to be due to the large
difference in technological advancements
between the creator of scp-2319 ein and
our own for all intents and purposes
scp-2319 ein is currently indestructible
by human means in theory scp-2319 ein
might be left vulnerable by a powerful
enough electromagnetic pulse
unfortunately this technology does not
yet exist since 1971 scp-2319 ein has
been the recipient of an unending stream
of electromagnetic based communications
originating in the
Guilhem Galaxy roughly three million
light-years from Earth the means of
scp-2319 inés travel to our solar system
and the means of its communications are
all unknown from 1971 to 1985 scp-2319
ein continuously received a single coded
message went through code-breaking and
translation efforts appeared to be a
command to repair the damage it incurred
upon entering our solar system at this
time the barrier array was established
to intercept these messages this
coincided with a period of radio silence
from the origin of the communications
until 1996 when a different order began
transmitting the barrier array has thus
far prevented scp-2319 ein from
receiving this command see addendum
$23.99 comm log scp-2319 ein discovery
notes the CP $23.99 was originally
observed albeit unknowingly by giovanni
cassini
in 1665 the following is taken directly
from Cassini's journal on the event
translated from Italian to English
October 8th 1665 I have observed
something extraordinary in the heavens
last night as I gazed through my
looking-glass I saw what appeared to be
a star of great luminance streak through
the far reaches of our solar system
I have never recorded an object moving
so fast it had surpassed the outer
planets in fewer than two hours as I
watched by my own two eyes I saw it slow
as it closed on Jupiter make a sharp
turn and disappear into the planet
itself
I saw many bursts of light afterwards
but although I continued to peer at it
until the Sun broke I saw no additional
disturbances in the night sky I must
continue to document these changes and
will alert my colleagues when the day is
upon thee
October 15th 1665 I took Peter to my
observation point last night but a week
from the night I saw the fire rain upon
Jupiter in the heavens he brought along
his own looking glass and together we
aimed our view upon the giant to our
surprise a magnificent change has
occurred where once the distant world
showed only bands of color there is now
a great red spot where the star came to
rest on the surface of Jupiter
Peter was incredulous of course that
such an amazing discovery could have
taken place before our very eyes I will
continue to take note of this October
18th 1665 tonight as I peered through my
looking-glass I swear on my life that I
observed what looked to me like
explosions and star bursts emanating
from our red spot I fear my mind is
playing tricks on me
there has been no record of such violent
outbursts by a heavenly body since the
dawn of astronomy I will consult with
Peter on the morrow and hopefully glean
from him some advice on the matter
October 19th
1665 Peter sees the same as I as I
approached him with my concerns he
leveled the same with me and through our
following discussion we concluded that
it must be a powerful reaction to the
falling star I saw upon the first night
and not a product of our own
shortcomings I am left wondering what
cataclysmic event must be taking place
on our heavenly neighbor our work to
document this must go on
this is addendum $23.99 - to be ours on
barrier unit 53 observed one of scp-2319
inés repair drones closing on a piece of
debris quickly determined to be part of
a damaged communications array because
of the nature of this specific component
and the ramifications of allowing a CP
$23.99 to recover it it was ordered that
barrier unit 45 fire upon the drone with
its onboard concussion batteries
batteries were discharged however the
drone appeared undamaged footage
obtained by barrier unit 53 shows that
while the payload in question was
launched to warns the repair drone it
was destroyed within 5 kilometers of the
target by additional charges originating
from scp-2319 ein command lost contact
with barrier unit 45 15 seconds after
initial discharge with video
observations showing that scp-2319 ein
the resulting spatial anomaly
originating the termination of barrier
unit 45 by barrier units 44 51 and 55
under no circumstances are any barrier
units to further engage scp-2319 ein or
drones released by a CP $23.99
addendum $23.99 - to see project gigas
after the events it was decided that
necessary force would be authorized to
destroy or incapacitate scp-2319 9 using
foundation resources as well as
resources from 45 nations notably a
platform
Moorhead's barren empty payloads and
warheads bearing EMP detonators was
launched and placed in orbit around two
Europa at hours with orders from 15
heads of state no.5
o 505 l5 no.5 the entire payload of
project gigas was launched toward
scp-2319 nine efforts to develop
alternative methods of eliminating
scp-2319 nine are currently underway
this is addendum $23.99 l5 so scp-2319
nine have you ever sat and wondered
maybe after you hear about a car
accident on a street you were just on or
a bombing in the city you were just
visiting just how lucky you are to be
alive just how many things have to go
right for you to continue to exist a few
seconds too late a few seconds too early
and somebody reaches for something they
dropped and a busload of people run into
another busload of people sometimes this
kind of thing does happen as we've seen
far too often but that's what we're here
for to protect those who can't protect
themselves from things that they
wouldn't even know to protect themselves
from we can't do it although as many
things that we've been able to contain
as many things as we've been able to
keep under lock that would threaten to
destroy us all still far too many remain
we can't do anything about whether
they're too big or too fast or too
powerful any of these things could blink
and wipe humanity from existence the
fact that they haven't done so yet it's
just luck a CP $23.99 however is
different we have little information
regarding scp-2319 inés motives origins
and full capabilities we do not
understand how it is capable of
communicating over such large distances
or why those who constructed it if it
was in fact constructed sent it to us in
the first place we do not know what
would happen if scp-2319 ein is able to
fully repair itself or if part of our
array would breakdown and a message
would get through we do not know this so
we must assume the worst judging by what
we've seen were scp-2319 ein to have
reached earth it would have led to more
timely destruction but sometimes
humanity gets a little help sometimes
something steps in the way of the
apocalypse for us and for scp-2319 ein
it was Jupiter as scp-2319 ein began to
slow its approach to earth Cassini saw
what we've been able to ascertain that
scp-2319 ein struck IO was damaged and
was unable to escape the gravitational
pull of Jupiter its weapons activated as
they were intended but it was Jupiter
that experienced doomsday not us
eventually though
it's likely that scp-2319 ein will
resume full functionality and will
likely be able to pull away from Jupiter
and proceed to its target as of now we
can keep hurling bombs and emps at it
all we want but we've got no indication
than any of it well so much as scratch
the thing on the contrary
experience dictates they would do
nothing at all if this were to happen
now we would undoubtedly be destroyed
Jupiter has given us time for now SCP
$23.99 will remain there reassembling
itself while we devise some way to stop
it like it or not we're in an arms race
with this thing best guesses give us
something like 25 years until it is able
to hear past their dampening array until
then we must seize the opportunity that
has been laid before us we must use the
time we have been given and not let it
be wasted so we devised protocol
Legionnaire one gigantic EMP powered by
god knows what followed by a volley of
nukes enough to wipe out our
civilization a thousand times over a
blunt plan and simple and likely futile
our researchers and researchers around
the globe have yet to devise even a way
to deliver that kind of pulse let alone
a way to power it there is no indication
whatsoever that we will be able to
completely genero time or if it'll do
what is intended once it's completed but
we must try we must do something even if
we have to drain our banks and empty our
minds we must try not often do we get a
chance to see the swerving bus that will
end our lives and step out of the way
Jupiter unknowingly
has offered us that chance I suggest we
take him randyll McCowan director
barrier project
sike addendum $23.99 comm lock all
message is logged are to be understood
as having repeated themselves
continuously until either a new messages
logged or a logged instance of radio
silence 1971 unit is damaged repair it's
1985 updating orders
maintain position repair 1985 period of
radio silence barrier array is
established 1996 unit is out of range of
target proceed to planet number 3 in
system coordinates redacted repair 2015
unit is out of range of target proceed
to planet 3 in system coordinates
redacted priority is target cease
repairs ok on that note this concludes
our lecture for today thank you all for
listening goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre Bessette
thank you very much Andre your pledge is
very much appreciated if you would like
to know how you can get a personalized
thank e at the end of each of my videos
as well as some other really cool stuff
as well go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
[Music]
you